ochoa mica avevo visto mi chiamo
jennifer dei soffocati se sono lazio
dell'app di incontri online mi in cui
oggi si sta vedendo questo video è
perché gesù che vuole bene o perché
qualcuno dei tuoi amici della cerchia
che ti circonda si è rotto i [ __ ]
vederti in giro elemosinare centimetri
di neve che lo sappiamo che il sana vita
la via di un po anche tu sei single o
ancora peggio ti trovi in una situazione
indizi bieler da una parte se quella
persona che riesce in tep dire a
malapena il tuo basso ventre ma che allo
stesso tempo una certezza
gentile carino è in totale contrasto
corato sindrome da abbandono che ti
porta a scappare da tutte quante le
persone che ti inseguono mentre
dall'altra parte c'è quel manigoldo che
con una sola in posizione dello sguardo
riesce a incendiare di glutei che sette
seggi su una bistecca la fai subito
bella media ma che lo stesso tempo ti
dalle certezze in un salto col bungee
jumping sun sembra cattura bene se
indecisa su chi scegliere
nella risposta è semplice nessuno dei
due
nessuno dei due è il servizio che hanno
cambiato la vita di milioni di persone
ma adesso inutile che io stia qui ad abu
farti le palle sul perché dovresti
scegliere e passare a nessuno dei due
lasciamo che a parlare siano loro i
nostri clienti più soddisfatti e stop
giusto montaggio adesso venivo da vasta
relazione costa ragazza otto anni otto
anni marotto dei carcere sinceramente
devo essere sincera insincerità totale
praticamente io sempre ho usato e stesso
si può dire una parola
dov'è scopare praticamente per andare a
colmare questo vuoto che mi hanno
lasciato comunque è il divorzio dei miei
genitori che mi ha veramente stesa
completamente quando terrà in clijster
di maionese per far capire ok forse una
cosa che più persone hanno provato
accusate io so genuina so proprio
crostaceo a proprio nelle nelle mie
esternazioni
avete mai visto il sole sorgerà all
orizzonte
per andare poi a dormire ogni sera dall
altra parte non ho questa frangia mi
impedisce la visuale a un certo punto
stesso interesse sta minando dei
cantieri prima di una gru per del suo
carico lievi sul clan yammi non una
persona brava di quelle che tornava a
casa dalla testata moglie ero pugni ai
figli quello che è capito quello che
capita che uno può dio
però dall'altra parte perché magari
arriva qualcuno che però d'altro lato
cioè io ti dico ricordo ricordo e
ricordo è stato un periodo della mia
vita in cui proprio bob bob boeri e davo
proprio giù giù pesante questa canzone è
permesso di nascondere il mio finito ad
altre persone ma allo stesso tempo
scusate avevo un capello in bocca mentre
stavo a guardia degli otto anni mi
sentivo con rischi alla terza mano verso
le una di quelle proprio diritto fa
scomparisse capissi buon intenditor
poche parole
avevo bisogno e tensioni tra le piccole
cose per cioccolatino lasciando così ha
lasciato proprio il mio ex in bancarotta
perché lui voleva poi comprare è il mio
affetto si riusciva mi trattava come una
meritricio per un momento ho avuto
problemi l'autostima là fuori c'è molta
gente che per esempio ama dire di avere
una vista a 360 gradi e adesso a volte
con dottino fare il mio occhio riesco a
malapena vedere non fa una decina di
gradi forse una cosa però sulla quello
sempre visto in qualche modo non sa se
posso dire la mia sono state le
relazioni io innamorato cioè io che io
ho messo le corna war 2 2 volte a
settimana cercando gli amici miei che
fanno peggio che visse che le loro di
fare
ricordo questa cena di pesce dove ho
preso una pasta coi coriacei che è stata
pazzesca ma io so scappati i soldi i
ragazzi io non vedo io immagino ogni
anno uso spesso per esempio quando mi è
capitato di tirar fuori il mio orecchio
per ascoltare ciò che succedeva attorno
a me mi chiedevano perché ti sei
innamorato dell'ennesima persona che ti
ho mandato un uccello in dna è pensato
che fosse amore ho sempre visto quello
che succedeva da fuori questo a me
faceva se il tipo vivo tipo mi nonno e
questo e ho perso la testa come mi nonno
quando gli e cascato il pianoforte
davanti si milano sta qua nuovo che sta
sotto ai miei amici ed i due migliori
amici mi ami fratelli e questi qua sopra
franceschino e lo sboro ria
ricordo che poi suscita di lynn sorpresa
la candida all'ugola questo gruppo di
camionisti perché i coriacei soffre di
siciliano perché mi guardavano io ho
fatto ti guardi questi mi guardavano
tutto disprezzo questa gattina io ho
detto ciccio dall inferno l'inferno di
dante alighieri scrittrice bravissima
però non andava bene ragazzi così da
così a così come quando tagli
sufficiente cosa c'è di male
mandare uccello infatti mi sembra un
gesto intimo una cosa che faresti non
sto col tuo andrologo di fiducia col
prete che tim battezzato in qualche
senso vabbè per questa quale ha potuto a
guardia xiaomi via lazio ma in thalasso
pure vivi a che tanto ha preso al padre
astro guardo e dico così io appena ho
potuto ha visto saputo due sardi da
parte ho detto dignità il bussino questo
lupo risparmiato sul balsamo l'acquisto
migliore della vita avevo la dignità ma
so comprata che compra borsa completa
della dignità tesoro per fitto pomodoro
che prima gli specchi pur di brio con
piacere dalla faccia mia io adesso mi
sento meglio non ripenso ha fatto a
voglio solamente tra parti in causa per
un po di trucco grazie a st rosa iorio
ha più bisogno dal guardian c'è più
bisogno di quel anta strozza c'è bisogno
di milano non c'è più bisogno dei miei
amici ha bisogno di nessuno io se
continuerà così saltano le tempie
bramafam impegnava back to black
amo tutti a fine di anni di villanova
ragazze che lo dico a 27 anni così al
creatore nell'inferno di dante
ricordo ancora il giorno in cui i
tecnici del servizio sono venuti a casa
mia a picchiarmi di botte stato uno dei
momenti più erotici della mia vita
sinceramente da allora ho finalmente
intavolato con le nazioni immaginaria
con uno di loro adesso finalmente posso
mostrare la mia faccio senza paura e
freddo eccomi sono tornata la vostra
migliore amica zenital quante volte
lanciato la tua baffo micia nelle pause
di un dobermann allo sbaraglio
molte volte e store creato il profilo
della fidanzata del tuo ex
quanti profili falsi invece è creato per
commentare sotto rete foto e per credere
alle persone di avere veramente degli
amici e quante volte invece hai chiamato
ubriaca di notte quella persona alla
quale detto ti amo ma perché è finita
tra di noi brutta sfigato ci pensiamo
noi i nostri tecnici di nessuno dei due
verranno a casa vostra direttamente
allegarvi alle per spaccare qualsiasi
strumento tecnologico di comunicazione
al fine di impedirmi di commettere altre
cazzate torna ma la pergamena
l'inchiostro e alla preghiera il
medioevo ti aspetta il pacchetto ma non
i carri va subito a casa nostra con un
bracciale di cinque taglie più piccolo
il cui scopo è quello di
desensibilizzare i vostri arti al fine
di farli sembrare di quelli di qualcun
altro grazie a mano amica potrai
ricevere quella pacca sulla spalla la
carezza sul volto che nessuno ti ha mai
dato o magari quel che esplode nei se
vuoi rendere la situazione un pochino
più dolce romantica ma la nostra
promozione non finisce qui amica che le
prime dieci persone che chiameranno al
numero in sovrimpressione regaleremo a
soli 120 euro una consulenza che la
nostra psicologa anna lita che vi
spiegherà con un sorriso come mai siete
dei falliti riversando su di voi tutte
quante le sue ataviche frustrazioni
allora cosa aspetti chiama anche tu
nessuno dei due e sbrigati ad
accaparrarsi uno dei nostri meravigliosi
pacchetti nessuno dei due
perché scegliere qualcuno quando puoi
scegliere te stesso a montefano rosa lo
dico io e molti stili al canale
la shin pollice in su ma dimentica del
fascio di metto sotto lo sbarro in due
secondi
ok che pende da una pizzeria mano di un
altro piglio e quante faccio più bella
frenata